In a way I think people want it
to be confusing.
>> The people behind the scenes?
>> Yeah.
>> You got into a tussle
recently be Bill Maher.
>> I did.
>> About critical race theory
and wokeness.
When you look at the political
discourse in our country today
and the role that media plays in
it, what do you think?
It's difficult to try to find
truly unbiased reporting, news
that really is straight
shooters.
You know, this conversation I
had with bill, we're talking
about critical race theory.
And I think it's imperative that
it's taught, that we look at our
history much the same I think
that Germany has looked at their
history involve in the wars, one
and two, and embrace it and say
this is where we went wrong.
This is how it went wrong.
When I see the make America
great again, my comment is do
accept that that could possibly
be construed as a racist remark?
And most people, a lot of people
go how could that be racist?
Make America great again?
I said so just ask yourself,
from an African American
experience, when was it ever
great in America for the African
American?
When was it great?
So if you're making great again,
it's not including them.
>> To end this on a different
note, for all of the serious
talk, your co-stars on "Breaking
bad" say that you are a child
trapped in a man's body, and
that they've never known anyone
who found it so amusing to stuff
fruit down his pants.
>> That's -- you know, that kind
of rumor is what makes me smile.
>> Rumor or fact?
>> You know, there can be fact
to some of these things.
As someone who comes on a set
and I lead a cast, whether it's
on Broadway or the movie or
whatever, I want to -- I want to
protect and have fun with my
cast and crew.
And sometimes in the 16th hour,
everybody is dragging, and it's
like I think we need a little
perk.
And so I'll do something silly
or even borderline stupid in
order to make everybody wake up
and laugh and finish the work
before we all go home.
>> And what's the stupidest
piece of fruit you stuffed down
your pants?